CAPTURE ALL ALONG.
>> Tucker: THAT’S TOTALLY
WRONG.
YOU ARE THE FIRST TO CALL
ATTENTION TO ONE OF THIS THING.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>> Tucker: DAVID GARO IS A
HISTORIAN WHO’S WRITTEN
EXCESSIVELY ON THE FBI IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT BOOKS.
IN A PIECE FOR TODAY’S
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," HE SAYS
SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
SOME DEMOCRATS THINK WE ARE
REVERTING TO THE J. EDGAR HOOVER
ERA IN THE TREATMENT OF THE FBI.
MAKE IT FOR COMING ON.
WE SEARCHED --
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THE LAST HONEST
LIBERAL WHO WILL COMMIT TO THE
-- WHEN YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY THE
FBI WOULD NEVER DO THAT, YOU ARE
ATTACKING OUR GUARDIANS BY
ASKING THAT QUESTION, IS THERE
SOME HISTORICAL PRECEDENTS?
>> I’M VERY WORRIED, TUCKER,
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE ARE GIVING UP
THEIR PRINCIPLES, THEIR CIVIL
LIBERTY PRINCIPLES BECAUSE OF
THE INTENSITY OF THEIR PARTISAN
HATRED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AS YOU KNOW, I’M A LIBERAL
DEMOCRAT.
BUT WHAT WE’VE GOT HERE IS
DEMOCRATS FORGETTING THE HISTORY
OF THE FBI.
AND TAKING UP THESE ANTI-CIVIL
LIBERTY STANCES DEFENDING THE
FBI SIMPLY BECAUSE OF HOW
INTENSELY OPPOSED THEY ARE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE FBI DOES NOT HAVE A GOOD
PEDIGREE ON ELECTRONIC
SURVEILLANCE PRACTICES AND
EVERYTHING I’M AWARE OF AS A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT IS WHAT THE
BUREAU HAS BEEN REALLY DECEPTIVE
WITH THE FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
COURT IN APPLYING THIS EXTENDED
ELECTRONIC SURVEILLANCE OF
CARTER PAGE, THE VOLUNTEER TRUMP
ADVISOR.
LIBERALS AND PROGRESSIVES SHOULD
OPPOSE THE FBI’S BEHAVIOR
TARGETING MR. PAGE.
>> Tucker: ON CIVIL LIBERTIES
GROUNDS, HAVING NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE LARGER INVESTIGATION,
BUT ANY AMERICAN CITIZEN IS
HAVING THEIR CIVIL LIBERTIES
VIOLATED.
LIBERALS SHOULD CARE, RECOLLECT
MEXICO BASED
PRIMARILY
Mexico based
AND EXTENSIVELY IT APPEARS ON
THE DODGY DOSSIER.
THE STEELE DOSSIER IS C-R-A-P.
THE FBI RELIED ON THAT’S GOING
TO FEDERAL JUDGES TO SURVEY ALL
AMERICAN CITIZENS, THAT’S
OFFENSIVE TO ME AS A LIBERAL